and you mentioned the eagles
they pulled off the victory last night
somehow over the 49ers we all thought
the 49ers were going to win the eagles
twitter account did their victory lap
after the game you know look where where
where are those twitter accounts when
we're right when we pick those teams to
lose do they say anything then that's
what drives me crazy like go thump your
chest when you win okay hey
congratulations you're not as bad as
everybody thought you were
congratulations you're slightly better
than the bad team that everybody thought
you were and you found an acorn and or a
shamrock stuck somewhere last night
against the 49ers but this to me was
more about the 49ers having their bubble
burst nick mullins talk about him
supplanting jimmy garoppolo not after
last night
yeah not after last night
i mean yeah womp is right i mean he's
going to be relegated to the third
string after last night i mean it's
really there's not much more to say than
that
it started from the very start of the
game the first throw of the game was a
wide open slant that was going to be
caught and run for 15 to 20 yards the
second play of the game was kyle use
check faking the run right he's running
up
he'd still be running he'd still be
running sorry by now right
horrible pocket presence fumbling stupid
interception when you're in field goal
range
horrible pick six at the end of the game
miss throws everywhere i mean they lost
the game there's no other way to say it
because of nick mullins that's just
that's just a simple fact of the matter
and philadelphia you know they're tough
and gritty and carson wentz is gritty
that way he just kept hanging in there
ugly as hell getting beat up i'll run
for six i'll jam it in here for four
four yards with this throw and he got it
done so yeah oh i see yeah we're eating
it on sunday night football oh you
showed us congratulations you one and
two and one eagles
you're not as bad as we all
unanimously believed you were
congratulations but
i'm telling you that last interception
that was like i saw somebody point this
out on twitter and i think it was
appropriate that that was neil o'donnell
in super bowl xxx throwing the ball to a
wide open larry brown like what the hell
i did you s instant did you have like
temporary insanity where you thought you
were playing for the eagles last night
that's how bad it was well it was it was
that bad the it really hit the trifecta
last night with nick mullins i mean
stupid mistakes not seeing the field the
right way and then also to th to that
ball specifically you're talking about
and it happened about five other
footballs i thought during the night
the ball just he physically he wasn't
good the ball just came out of his hand
off the side of his hand and he he like
shanked it like a guy on the driving
range you know you you know four like
you think you're going to hit the ball
down the middle no he shanked it and hit
it 700 yards left
uh that that's what he did there in the
quarterback terms it was an out route to
the left side
he's just got to throw it high and soft
and it's going to be an easy completion
and he threw it
no joke 10 yards short of the target and
didn't get any uh what do i say arc on
the football so it was just an
all-around bad look and you know again
cj beathard you saw when he came in
he certainly was a more natural of a
thrower and you know he was reckless in
his time and that's why he got benched
for mullins uh you know two years ago
but but regardless you know it did give
them a jump start but i don't think
we're gonna see nick mullins in there
anytime soon if jimmy garoppolo is not
back next week
so you think it'll be bethard next week
i don't see
i don't see how you can go back to nick
mullins after a game like that last
night that'll be one of those where it's
gonna the coaches are gonna go look at
it and go oh my gosh he played so
horrible and the players are gonna even
go man nick struggled not even knowing
how bad he really played really i mean
that that'll be
one that's unavoidable to me to where i
would think shanahan would end up going
with cj beathard if garoppolo is not
ready to go
well uh it's amazing how quickly
one three-hour stretch can change how we
feel about a team because we thought hey
here are the 49ers the next man up
they're going to keep winning
and and remember this
that schedule for the 49ers
eventually becomes really hard
the likes of which we have never seen
although i'm exaggerating there but look
at that starting week six rams at
patriots at seahawks packers at saints
at rams bills
you better hope jimmy g's back and you
better hope that he's ready to play the
best football of his life
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports